New York City baby listen up and listen
good the tickets for the third show at
the Gramercy theater are going faster a
couple of tickets left do yourself a
favor and grab them before they're gone
yeah time is running out gang very
limited tickets left to the show on
February 3rd Friday night get them while
supplies last we'll see you there we're
gonna blow the roof off the place
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage it's a little show we
sit there with your favorite comedians
and we find that if they're going to be
classy or if they're just a mega piece
of trash I'm your host stage Foley
coming at you on a beautiful day we're
down here at antodi's basement she's
upstairs just got a fresh bag okay
she'll be out for a couple hours but the
do not disturb sign on her bedroom door
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me unamused this week he is the
CEO of are you garbage he is an
international businessman he's my best
pal in the whole wide world and I love
him give it up for KJ Kevin James Ryan
everybody yeah thank you Foley what's up
everybody thanks for tuning in as always
make sure your rate if you subscribe on
iTunes full video available on YouTube
and as you those numbers are and then
obviously the greatest website of all
time
www.patreon.com are you garbage check it
out gang big party over there love that
money and having a nice quick shout out
to our producer X Jordan Air the magic
man makes us all look good works the
ones and twos crosses the t's and that's
the eyes give it up for T-Bone
mcgruffins it's Toby McMullen everybody
come on hey what's up dudes what's up
T-Bone dude this is a thing we got a
legend in the background
very cool pants are busted gang the long
hair is not lying we could not be more
excited to have our incredibly and I
mean incredibly special guest here with
us today for the first time he is a
legendary stand-up comedian actor writer
director and producer you might have
seen him in but not limited to here we
go sit tight because the list is long
and distinguished we got the Ben Stiller
show we got the cable guy waiting for
Goffman The Drew Carey Show Men in Black
one and two no big deal Tenacious D news
radio Small Soldiers Strangers With
Candy Ghost World Doctor Doolittle 2
Pootie Tang scary movie two we got King
of the Hill we got just shoot me we got
Eternal Sunshine in the Spotless Mind oh
my God we got school for scoundrels we
have Family Guy we have I'm not there
that's enough Alvin and the Chipmunks
franchise no it's not baby we're going
all the way we're still in the 90s I
think
we got Kung Fu Panda one two and three
we got Tim and Eric we have Megamind
Modern Family Rick and Morty Obvious
Child Community Marin Kimmy Schmidt
Archer Big Mouth station 11 Gordon
Kimmel WTF with Mark Maron we got Conan
Fallon Bill Maher tough crowd Letterman
he's seen it all and done it all but
here's the here's the turkey right here
Creator star the increasingly poor
decisions of Todd Margaret Creator star
animated series on Comedy Central freak
Show we got Mr Show with Bob and David
of course 84 episodes of Arrested
Development he has multiple stand-up
specials an album including 2022 special
I'm from the future and he has a brand
new spring tour starting this spring
again give it up for the one the only Mr
David Cross
come on
no Amelia Earhart story
I was reporter number three reporter
number three there was a Criminal Intent
in there too yes yes there was suing me
buddy thank you so much for coming and
sitting down with us thanks for being
reminding me of my all the work yeah
you've been killing it Jesus I gotta
check my residuals yeah I gotta check
the mailbox man that thing might be full
stop by the SAG office on my way yeah
buddy what is the backstory of David
Cross give us the full scoop where are
you from
um well I mean it started going
originally it started in a Petri dish
[Laughter]
you know still we're still waiting to
see if it was a success what the
hypothesis was yeah
um no I was born in Atlanta a long long
time ago and then moved around a whole
bunch almost uh yearly even sometimes
less than a year uh always in a new
place until I was was nine and then
moved back to Georgia
um and then was there until I was 19
moved to Boston for nine years then
moved to LA for nine years and then
uh moved to New York and been here soon
and here we are what is uh what did your
mom and dad do that you moved around so
much
um well my mom was a homemaker you know
and my dad just got fired a lot
I'm constantly getting fired it wasn't
promotionally you know he was one of
those
um he was one of those like uh kind of
pathological uh liar uh exaggerator guys
who was very much you know the like you
can't fire me I quit yeah that's my
favorite kind of guy and it's like well
we you can't come back here to quit we
fired you you're already like five days
ago you're what do you you know so yeah
he uh he was uh just a whole string of
crazy jobs right and then he left us and
then he left us uh shortly after we
moved to Georgia that's when you got
back where you were until you were 19.
yeah gotcha okay all right and what's
your mom did your mom start working
after that yeah I mean she had no she
was a school teacher when they met
um and he was and he's from England uh
but then he joined the army and I don't
know why he they were in Ann Arbor
together for some reason she was
teaching I know she was teaching and uh
I don't know what he was you know
you won't be on leave and go to Ann
Arbor right now so the sunny beaches of
Ann Arbor really tear it up in Michigan
and uh r r and uh and then
and she eventually she had no real
skills outside of teaching and we were
in um kind of rural suburban Georgia and
zero money like in debt got your debt
and um it took her a while to uh get
credit you know I think she got I think
the way it went was she got a gasoline
card like a sure
she'll be company or something
um and then was able to pay that off and
then got a Sears card I want to say and
then paid that up so it was a long
you know over well over a year starting
with a gas card yeah I think that was it
you know that's all we had really little
I mean no money and uh and then she got
a job what was it oh her first job was
which actually
is was I'll tell you all right so our
first job was at a uh
um little tiny little place where they
were like trailers there were three
trailers in this like Industrial Park
um like literally like mobile home type
gotcha trailers uh that sold
um uh copier supplies like toner and ink
and like cold calling that kind of thing
and their motto was the inspiration for
uh uh a Mr show kind of an iconic Mr
show thing because Bob used to love
listening to my stories like he couldn't
they were crazy that's where Randy Dobbs
came from and that's where uh so Pitt
Pats take it from me I love you there
um I can't remember the name of the
company and when I say company it was
like you know Six Women yeah what year
are we talking about is this maybe 75 I
would have been like 11 when he took off
I think because that's old school 70s
printers yeah yeah where'd they store
the ink yeah well they were all like you
know the cartoon yeah they're huge huge
yeah exactly and uh
um and then
so their their logo was uh no we love
you or something it was and it was it
was like so and it was like balloons and
a and a little a cupid that said I we
love you or something so weird a
printing company it's not even a
printing company they're just selling my
toner and ink and whatever and it's like
how is this gonna work nobody gives a
[__] and uh and then so I you know that
was one of the stories I told Bob uh
because he would pepper me with
questions and then then that became pit
Pat's Global chems thing was taken from
me I love you yeah that's funny man
um what did you guys live in when you
guys what do you when you got settled
there was an apartment apartment a house
no never a house uh we were in a series
of apartment complexes
um and like you know you see all over
America they were these uh just shitty
you know put together sure quickly cheap
materials but they all had grandiose
names for things that weren't anywhere
remotely right or whatever yeah you know
Grand Creek
sandalwood and uh Sandalwood Manor Sandy
yeah
it's on the turnpike and uh and then
Noble Creek was another one there
probably wasn't a body of water no
nobility there's no nobility to be found
and uh and yeah we were just in a bunch
of apartments and how many brothers and
sisters how many how many are there two
younger sisters okay uh we don't know
we don't know the gender of the one that
was aborted but uh my my sister and I
used to say we used to call arp
our fourth child that we never had
because we had no money and then my mom
went and got an abortion
um this is what she was still with your
father yeah yeah okay um oh she [__]
around oh my God Town [__] yeah wait
are you serious no not at all not at all
my mom's gonna say I'm putting two and
two together with the printer thing I
think that was a sex line I don't know
what's going on with the cupid uh so um
so yeah two sisters two younger sisters
and did she ever remarry or was there a
stepfather involved or anything no no
she barely she's uh very
anti-social
um
like social in a small Church way but
but very like uh I think went on
literally two dates I want to say where
we we were encouraging yeah like get out
there get a you know she had one
friend in the apartment complex and uh
they were they were it was the kind of
thing even as uh even young uh I felt a
sense of like they were being charitable
to my mom in a sense God like socially
like yeah I truly did like her but I
mean she would that was it it was just
uh uh and they were younger you know and
um and I just felt and it may not even
be true but I just had this sense of
like oh they're being nice nice maybe
after the divorce and all that kind of
stuff they wanted to you know they
wanted to be cool to her I get that yeah
they then they were and they were uh it
just and I I it could be off and it was
just a feeling I had when I was you know
12 13 14. sure you know
and what did you start working early too
yeah I had a uh uh in the kitchen of
provinos Italian restaurant
uh in Roswell uh off of whatever that
road was the only Road there and uh and
it worked there from when I was like 14
and 15. totally illegally sure yeah yeah
yep washing dishes me and uh two friends
um how was the food it was good Georgia
Italian restaurant it was and we'll get
this the the guy who ran it was Austrian
his name was Miss Mr girlitz yeah and uh
they're known for their Italian cuisine
and uh and and also like Roswell in the
70s was nothing there was nothing there
there was nothing so uh but it was I
mean you know I liked it and we all
stole food you know just stole
everything I stole a five gallon uh can
of clams once which I which I had to do
[Laughter]
the restaurant they had uh started like
breaking ground in this construction
thing to do to put up like a um some
small office building or something and
and so I was able to get the clams from
the storage place and then move them
over to another place and they keep them
covered and then move them to a place
kind of by the door and then waited you
know and I had a idea of like when the
smoke breaks were happening when this
was happening and then I got it finally
got it out the door without making too
much noise and turned it on its side and
rolled it all the way to where the
construction thing was and and then when
my mom came to pick me up uh she was in
on it she was fine she became an
accomplice yeah
I hope you got a lot of them gleaning at
that you're not gonna rat me out because
you're you're going with me yeah you got
clam juice on your hands too yeah I'll
go get some toner hey what'd you bring
it back to the house and crack the can
open and eat it yeah we had you know
spaghetti and clams for a couple for six
years six months yeah
Ah that's awesome
um do you remember the name of your
local pizza place or did they do pizza
at the Italian joint uh no the the
um
there was a
uh not in the or not in the first two
apartment complexes they were real again
it was really rural but the last one
which was uh again noble noble Creek
um if you went down to the main road
there was like a um like a longer strip
mall like uh gotcha so they're being
shopping I remember there was like a
Steak and Ale uh if you remember that
and then and then there was like a
little yeah a little shopping strip
um and there was a pizza place called
Gino's
respectable it's all right and I I I'm
fuzzy on this because I would have been
about 13 but I
or maybe it was like you know by the
time I got there I was probably 15 and I
went on a air quote to date on air quote
right and um and didn't have enough
money and I remember that the pizza was
black olives I remember they were black
olives on the pizza and I literally
washed dishes to get out of it yeah for
for real yeah how short were you was it
like yeah
this is back this is back then I mean it
wasn't much
could have told you a part owner I had
to run in the kitchen real quick I don't
remember uh any of the details like
except for for whatever reason I
remember black olive pizza
um maybe that was it maybe because I got
extra toppings
are you folks in need of any clams by
any chance do a little trade uh Sports
situation in high school you play any
sports
no
um uh I I was the the
I wouldn't say I played any sports but I
certainly was the play thing of a lot of
the athletes there gotcha yeah yeah you
know put me in trash cans and whatnot
gotcha but uh no I but I I mean I I was
uh I I was pretty active with swimming
from from when I was like five years old
yeah and I uh that was really good I uh
and I the team was on uh the
was a highly ranked team in in the state
and Roswell and the uh um and I went to
invitationals Junior AAU and stuff like
that and and did well I was uh I was I
had lots of you know medals and ribbons
and things like that
um and then I that stopped when I was
14 I want to say and then I went to a
summer instead of swimming I went and
did and I I remember very well having
a very grown-up kind of realization that
because there was this guy in a uh that
I would always race against super nice
guy uh in North Carolina there they were
like the dynamos I think they were
called and they were one of the top
ranked in the Southeast uh swim teams
and um
and this kitten we got along really well
and I would see him you know two three
times a year always beat me I never ever
ever beat him and I was good but he was
better and I remember having this
um
like I just understood
that I'm never going to be a great
swimmer I'll be a good swimmer but I
just don't have that thing in me and I
don't I just didn't care as much I
wasn't as driven and uh
as as other people I saw who did it and
I loved it I loved
you know swimming competitively I didn't
like um the uh practices which were
really really grueling and hard but I
loved I loved it I just knew and I just
sort of drifted away from that effect of
like yeah and and then I did this summer
and set up for the first time I did a uh
I did this like Theater Camp type thing
where there was like acting exercise I
knew I wanted to do something like stand
up or formative you know films or
whatever and and then I we ended up
doing what was it some musical Music Man
South Pacific no it was like a little
more uh maybe it was West Side Story and
uh no that was when I was in anyway I
whenever I did I ended up going to that
school it was a magnet school School of
the Arts and I and I would say kind of
Saved My Life gosh and not not in a in a
figurative way in a little way I think I
don't know what would have happened if I
was still just going to that high same
High School in Roswell night so we went
we moved closer into the City and um and
then my sister started going there and
it was uh uh you know completely
different it was uh diverse and it was
uh way more urban
um and and you didn't have PE or
anything like that you had
you know there was like whatever you had
uh theater musical theater or dance or
whatever it was all part of the same
thing and totally turned me I met really
cool blossomed a bit yeah yeah and then
and then was happier uh
um because I was I wouldn't say I was
I mean I hesitate to to I don't want to
sound over dramatic but I thought about
suicide a lot not in a real way like I'm
planning it but I just and I and I think
if I probably would just run away and
move to New York which was something in
my head you know and uh
um just dropped out of high school I
think but but that so that really just
put me in a give you a purpose okay yeah
excitement of course there's like comedy
Now was like a whole part of it and uh
um yeah it was it was a big that's great
man look at that what a [__] story
I know I know it's not that's kind of a
boring movie unless what are you talking
about if you're the lead oh wait no the
clamp the clam scene the clam scene
would be amazing that's our second act
come on I got it all figured out with
the soundtrack picked out talking to
Netflix
Kip how about that liquid IV baby uh I
feel like a doctor when I'm taking
liquid IV let me tell you something
about this liquid IV gang do yourself a
favor it hits those electrolytes where
you need them uh-huh used it this
morning why because we got all banged up
like that all banged up had one of those
in the morning then filled it up to go
to the gym powered through to work out
with the trainer good good stuff love
that liquid IV yeah they were nice
enough they sent about 7 000 packets of
that stuff I got it coming out the ears
I put it in my cereal I put it on a
steak I do everything with it all right
fantastic it's free from gluten dairy
and soy liquid IV contains three times
the electrolytes of traditional sports
drink there you go uh grab your liquid
IV in bulk nationwide at Costco or you
can get 20 off when you go to liquid
iv.com use the code garbage at checkout
that's 20 off anything you order when
you shop better hydration today using
promo code garbage at liquid iv.com want
to say one more gosh darn time take a
pen take a pad put it in your notes app
text a friend yell at somebody do it it
is
a promo code garbage at liquid iv.com do
it
manscape manscape let's go taking it up
a notch huh you don't use the ball
trimmer for your beard which I did today
but now you don't have to I know they
got the beard hedger uh-huh 20 different
lengths talk about getting cleaned up
for the weekend give yourself a nice
Fade Out let's go that's fantastic yeah
uh it gives you 20 hair cutting lights
like the big Med said uh you can go for
Mr Clean the Grizzly Adams everywhere in
between they got you covered because
manscape takes care of your balls and
now your beard yeah and since manscaping
someone Fade up the nuts a little bit
give them the high and tights and since
manscape wants you to have all the tools
for the job they're throwing in a beard
brush comb and scissors to make you look
like a million dollars there you go I
would say you look like a billion
dollars but that's just me of course uh
right now uh you can get 20 off and free
shipping with code garbage at
manscaped.com that is 20 off which ain't
nothing to shake a stick at plus free
shipping hachimachi with code garbage at
manscape.com manscaped beard hedger one
stroke one guard 20 lanes now back to
the show all right any pets growing up
what was the bad situation
um when I was uh uh I think about
uh when I was born the our family dog
was about four and a half months old
um named Charlie Brown uh Charlie Brown
it was a a brown uh large one of those
large French poodles and uh and then he
ended up having uh God it was this we
hit this is her still
this is for the movie this is for the
story all right so we were in Syracuse
New York
um and I'm uh probably
uh
I guess it would have been nine or just
about to turn nine it was Winter
um I was born in April but it was uh but
Sarah you know winter and Syracuse
yeah no no we were living there oh you
were living it's one of those ones okay
one of the spots you ended up with
Syracuse yeah and so it's fourth grade
whatever whatever age that is uh I guess
ten nine nine ten yeah no I was I was
nine when I moved to back to Georgia so
it would have been uh I guess anyway
um
and it was a particularly brutal cold
snowy uh night and I had uh you remember
on the in the back of comic books I
don't know how old you all but but there
were things like oh then you won't the
things you could buy you would sell them
and then get yeah uh prizes or things so
I wanted to watch I think that was it it
was one of those LED you know red you
press it in the Red digital yeah yeah I
wanted this watch and uh and so you it
was greeting card so I was uh you get a
big box of green cards and uh to go sell
them and I'm going door to door and it's
snowing it's coming down those coming
down and uh uh
and it's and it's just really hard and
it's all it's all all I had I all I
could do really and I remember selling a
couple again people just taking pity on
a neighborhood kid I'm seeing this in
black and white widescreen yeah IMAX and
um I was thinking 3D but just the lower
half is three
now we're the top half is black and
white you both get to share your vision
compromise
and uh anyway it was just all brutal and
uh you know so cold when you come and
you can't unzip your zipper you have no
motor control over here anyway came in I
didn't really have a very successful
night and even people just kind of some
people being kind of rude was the dog
with you on making these rounds no no no
all right I came back to find out that
my dog had died and uh and then
everyone's oh the the first thing sorry
this is even better so uh my
sister wasn't in no my [__] get this
right
somebody wasn't in the room
and uh I guess my dad wasn't there and
my mom had said we lost a member of the
family tonight and uh oh my God and so
I'm like what oh my God then then and
then to make it worse it turns out it
wasn't my dad it was actually my dog
that I had growing up and uh and then my
little sister and I'm I start crying and
my other sister Wendy's crying and then
uh and my little sister goes can we get
a cat now finally yeah and cleared out
some space and then uh and then shortly
after that we moved down to Georgia Down
to Georgia yeah did you get a new dog
from there no no more family pets I had
one here I just who uh um
just you know relatively recently I had
a you know put down euthanized and uh um
well it's it got me like you know nine a
good nine minute bit in the last special
everybody needs a closer you know yeah
if you go to
um officialdavidcross.com get I'm from
the future you'll hear all about my dog
and what happened and what that was like
huh okay ever arrested when you were a
kid
uh when I was a kid no no as an adult
um I spent the night in lock up in La
nice yeah
um was drinking or uh I had been
drinking but I wasn't like I had a
couple cocktails and knocked over a bank
but it's uh uh it wasn't the clams again
was it it was still the clan they
finally found attracted they tracked me
down yeah you're the punk we're looking
for
and luckily I had still had some left it
was five gallons it was a lot of clean
and it would always whenever I moved I
would bring those clams with me oh man
oh that's good stuff okay
let's see here where'd it go you know
how to tie a tie
uh yes and no I could do it he never
gives you a straight answer this one
he's all over the place I'm being honest
I'm not being I'm a complex I can tell I
could I can do this guy you know the
whatever that one's called the standard
one but uh the Windsor when the Windsor
I guess yeah okay down but uh whenever I
do it like uh on set somebody will I
would say 95 of the time come undo it
and tell you it's not do it right cool
and so yes and no okay so going from
that background which wasn't easy that
was tough growing up like that when you
started making a little cash was there a
silly purchase how are you with money
no I'm very very good with bunny okay I
but there were plenty of silly purchases
nothing uh what was like the first big
check
um what was for Ben Stiller and I got uh
I want to say
uh whatever the scale was but I want to
say
um
2750 that was the first big thing that
was the Ben Stiller show yes that was uh
um that was what early night what year
was that early 1990
three yeah so you're out in L.A you're
doing it you're doing your thing you
land that show and I had never had and
this is absolutely true and I'm
including everything you know uh Bar
Mitzvah money anything I never had had
more than a couple hundred dollars ever
yeah and
um and then up to this point up to this
point uh I mean I was living with three
four other housemates uh in Somerville
and Massachusetts
um and
you know I just remember being like I'm
sick of being cold and hungry sure uh um
and I because I actually this is so
stupid and embarrassing really
embarrassing but I was I really debated
whether to take this job uh because I
had this stupid
inflated sense of like stand up is pure
and I'm Pure in Art and it was
ridiculous and uh I mean I'm taking a
job on the Ben Stiller show say what to
take the job on the Ben Stiller dude I'm
well to move to Hollywood and uh it was
so annoying and we use a purist I mean
all I was missing was like a beret and a
closed cigarette and so I have a
baguette
and then you know I did it and then and
uh and of course it was the best
decision I ever made and uh
um but yeah so I started
uh uh I started getting these checks and
then I uh uh was staying and I was
crashing out of friends and all the the
sudden you know my bank account that I
could see went from you know twenty
seven hundred dollars to fifty four
hundred dollars and then a week later
there we go and it's just and I'm I'm in
the I've got five digits now yeah and I
and it's crazy and I can't and and I'm
and I'm not looking at the the prices on
the menu yeah and I'm just going yeah
and I'm and now a lot of we're
experiencing that now at four right like
literally right now yeah it's great
that's awesome first dumb thing I did
was I got my mom a like this glass this
fancy glass phase a sculptures thing uh
and send it to her
um pretty classy yeah and if she could
you know didn't care less but sure she
was very nice it was it was uh it was
like you know it was one of those uh the
thought is sure did you see him like I'm
Really Gonna wow with this and give her
this and where was she living at the
time was she back in Georgia she was in
like an apartment complex yeah yeah
gotcha and uh um
and
you know but I mean it was a nice
gesture but it was uh it was the first
you know expensive thing we took 500
bucks what was it oh no it was like
probably
275 300 bucks something like that to
know jet skis or anything like that no
I'm not I'm not that kind of guy I don't
the the thing that I'm really frivolous
with and I justify it by saying it's
potentially it's an investment but I'm
so I mean the money I put into it does
not even come close to the value but um
is baseball cards okay all right I've
been collecting baseball cards for a
while and I do have some
you know uh valuable cards but all in
all when you take the decades I've been
doing it like I put way way way more
money yeah than I've got did you do that
as a kid as well was that something you
did as a kid uh initially yeah and then
uh and then I stopped for a long time
and then and uh this is gonna mean
nothing to except to a handful of people
but in 89 Donruss it was the year before
um Upper Deck came out with a hologram
sure and Donruss had all these mistake
cards and me and some friends foolishly
believe like we're gonna be millionaires
because the sports card is you know got
the got glavina and we thought and we
literally just any money I had I would
go buy these dumb cars we'd sit or we'd
all break our packs and uh and they're
you know
[Laughter]
that got me interested when I was older
but I buy I get baseball cards like a
rich guy would you know what I mean like
I get
uh you know spend a bunch of money on uh
unopened boxes that I wait a few years
and then open them to see if there's
what's up yeah what's the most expensive
single card you have
um I have a uh Sandy Koufax uh uh
secular card I have a uh a not in good
condition but it personally it's my
favorite card is a Hank Aaron rookie
card that wouldn't get much because it's
really not great condition but I [__]
love it and it's all there I love it
just looking at that means great and uh
as far as like you know crazy refractor
green one of one autograph cards I have
a Babe Ruth upside down or something
like that yeah on a plane uh on a bike
on a biplane you skateboarding yeah you
dropped 10 G's on misprints
all right that's it at heart that is a
dirtbag mentality I'm like I'm gonna buy
up all these best to hopefully get paid
off in the long run yeah that's the
Dirtbag mentality I have uh Babe Ruth
eating a hot dog getting sucked off by
some Hollywood Scarlet in a in a bathtub
that's worth nothing you believe that
it's a little dog-eared what are you
gonna do
that's good stuff okay that's pretty
classy how many suits do you own
you gotta have a lot of Suits right a
lot of award shows and stuff like that I
haven't the last time I wore a suit I
believe was my wedding and that was
something that was over 10 years ago and
I couldn't fit into it I've you know got
this guy going this little fella hey
hello hey buddy and um but I don't
really own a suit
that I have suit jackets and I have and
I have uh like nice pants but I don't I
don't own a suit I guess because tuxedo
no no tuxes no okay
all right do you breath brush your teeth
in the shower
no I'm gonna do that a lot of people do
it why time I don't know why because
they're garbage how much time does it
take to brush your teeth by the sink
what about peeing in the shower oh sure
all right and the sink I'll pee in the
sink while I'm brushing my teeth
Time Saver this guy's got a lot going on
do you brush my teeth when I take a [__]
in the shower in the shower yeah while
making scrambled eggs what am I gonna do
with all that extra time do you floss
every day no I should though you don't
flush everything all right mouthwash guy
um you know what I was because I I have
really really really bad teeth uh um but
I think it's just genetics my dad a
British British lineage yeah right my
dad had terrible teeth and um and I got
his shitty teeth
um uh
so I've had all this uh surgery oral
surgery and dentals been implants and
things like that and uh and the guy's
like you know you need to use this
whatever what you know ten in one stuff
with the oral type thing yeah Oral Care
stuff and then I read this thing just
recently uh it's not good for you that
it's you know of this dentist lady in
Sweden is horrified at uh the stuff
because you uh and she broke it down so
you're the the toothpaste you use has a
lot of fluoride in it which is the thing
the ingredient we need more than
anything else
but the mouthwash has way less fluoride
so you're just getting rid of all the
fluoride if you use it after you brush
it afterwards so all right that makes
sense not bad so thank you internet yeah
saved my life once again
uh hmm anybody in your family pronounce
the days of the week is this the show
this is the show bro it's crazy it's
just so stupid so you just
ask you wild questions if you haven't
thought about yeah all right and how do
you sell this show we just do it it's
all self-produced oh nice nice it's all
just us that's great
you hear that Hollywood we don't need to
take that unless you want to cut a
jacket Ben Stiller take your 2700 and
cram it like we're on the Paramount lot
and you're like how the [__] did you
guys get in here now what kind of soap
do you use
you stuff a dog's bar or the the gel no
no jails I hate gels yeah just the bar
just the bar I'm a dove bar man myself
yeah great and now are you in a are you
in a house or an apartment now I'm in a
house yeah
um
bathroom glass shower yes glass shower
separate tub yes
that's all right for New York
where's the typical uh cross family
vacation where would you guys go uh we
have all my uh except for I've one
sister in North Carolina but everybody
else is in Georgia so we are back quite
a bit there but um and then my sister
and her wife have a boat uh there's like
there's a big lake uh north of Atlanta
Northeast called Lake Lanier so we'll
we'll get uh we'll rent a house okay and
and it'll be you know my family and uh
you know my wife and daughter and then
other friends and stuff and we'll stay
we'll stay at the house for like five
six days and uh and the the lake is
it's heavily Trump but it's uh the lake
itself is just beautiful and gotcha it
is great and uh and it's it's great it's
nice it's fun it's awesome any Disney
World no no nothing like that no okay uh
Southern Man how do you feel about the
boiled peanut I [__] love boiled
peanuts are you kidding who doesn't like
boiled peanuts I love them yeah [__]
them [__] those people I didn't try them
they're great yeah oh my God here and
I'll tell you I'll tell you what if the
best boiled peanuts I've ever had uh is
a there's a a great room in East Atlanta
called The Earl which stands for Easter
and that's where I had him for the first
time Sean Patton oh that's great yeah
it's crazy they're the best spoiled
peanuts real has the best boiled penis I
was just there uh it's a great one shows
it's great that's an awesome room I've
been doing stuff there since you know
early hey shout out to the girl food
there's top shelf that's great that's
great I had a killer that whole little
section of Atlanta because I remember
when there was nothing there it was oh
yeah it's like that strip now yeah that
strip is great and there's a lot of good
stuff there but uh
um oh what's the name here's another
place you got to go to that doesn't open
until like 10 o'clock that
the octopus the octopus okay
um uh highly recommended that doesn't
it's like a place where a lot of the
chefs go in Atlanta and like that that's
like a house that they turned into a
restaurant lounge and it's uh yeah it
doesn't open until 10 p.m
um it's great uh but um yeah the Earl
best boiled peanuts okay all right I
love them you gotta go-to karaoke song I
do what is it so I have a couple
depending on what I'm trying depending
on the mood yeah exactly
um am I looking for a romance sure uh so
the one I do if I'm if people don't know
I sing or I'm gonna like surprise people
I just don't know I see is To Sir with
Love okay it has a high register
um can you sing like yeah yeah yeah I
can sing uh you know I would surprise
people with my sweet melodious tone and
uh yeah
so that I've been that's I've had going
on for a long time
but then if I'm just uh trying to piss
people off uh and I I've got a quick
little anecdote about this uh uh I will
do eat it by Weird Al okay okay and then
once I've heard a Weird Al song Donna
karaoke just do the original that's no
no no no no no and I'll tell you why
yeah I'll tell you why because it will
[__] piss people off because they
don't know the words no because they
don't they think it's beating beat it
and then it doesn't start the same way
and I was in yeah
we were uh on the roads it's going way
back
um it was was like uh early early tour
like uh I think was the bigger and
Blacker tour I think we were in West
Virginia and
I can't remember it was like teeny
redneck little town in fact I I used to
have a picture of the the thing like on
engraved in a plaque not hand written
but like you uh everyone must wear must
wear shoes and shirts uh in the lobby
like they had enough problems with these
they had to yeah they had to etch it and
stuff rednecks coming in and they had a
great you know like a plaque or whatever
you must wear shirts and [__] you know
yeah that would only let me tell you
again so there was a the one of the very
few places to do anything there was this
karaoke night at this bar and I went up
uh and I put my name in and everything
it's all locals and stuff and I went to
do eat it and the and the it starts you
know
you know and people start getting hyped
when that's they get started getting
excited and these women get up yay we
and then uh dance floor is filling up
and uh and then I start singing and it
was like that kind of slow and then
quickly but slowly like the realization
yeah what is he talking about custards
and pot what is this
making a mockery of Michael Jackson
exactly it was ridiculous and they
wouldn't and they wouldn't but they're
they were so self-conscious they
wouldn't allow themselves to dance even
though it's the same thing
exactly they were embarrassed like I'm
not gonna dance to you know a bunch of
fat chicks start hitting the floor yeah
turning it up I did the same thing when
I was 11 at a karaoke place in North
Carolina Weird Al song I got off and one
of the ways she's like did you write
those lyrics yourself
hey sign you to a record deal that
doesn't that doesn't speak weird of
weird uh speak good of uh Weird Al
though that they thought in 11 years
did an 11 year old write that uh
um you know here's a here's a true thing
do you know that Weird Al is truly one
of the nicest guys and I can imagine
the nicest guy yeah I'm fan of the Weird
Al yeah super nice guy about a lot of
tough guys playing the accordion yeah
a real [__] this guy's a real tight
ass how do you feel about the rotisserie
chicken
uh I mean I like it I'm ambivalent I
guess okay okay how do you guys feel
love them love them big fans it's trashy
yeah but as opposed to what just other
types of chicken or just no I guess the
rotisserie chicken would be the
trashiest of all the chickens oh I
disagree really I mean on my block it's
the
the you know the fried chicken the
shitty Fried Chicken that you know
people just throw on the streets it's
pretty good though yeah I guess it's he
comes off
it seems classier than it is I think is
the at the end of the day it's a six
dollar full but it's still um well you
can have cheap things that are classy
short but I would say the rotisserie
chicken is Light Years classier than
fried chicken I'll give you that I'll
give you that okay look at this score
one for me yeah all right worries on the
board where are you shopping now this is
where I come from you're a Whole Foods
guy no no where are you shopping over
there uh key foods go to Key Food down
the street for me yeah huh wow Keith
foreign
[Laughter]
have you ever gone ghost hunting
no what is that like ghosts looking for
ghosts yeah no anybody in the family
ever claimed to have seen a UFO no no
UFOs no can you do the Electric Slide
I mean I believe that I'm capable of
doing it but I prove it
how about the Macarena
uh again uh I don't have very good
Rhythm I will say that I'm not a good
dancer okay uh but I if I if I studied
for a couple months at uh the sorbonne
uh I could probably learn the Macarena
sure uh if we went over your house right
now what kind of water could you offer
us bottled water out of a Brita out of
the tap what do you got both tap and uh
filter the the button I don't use Brita
I use zero one okay that's pretty glassy
fridge open this way double door yes it
does what's the uh what's the brand sub
Z what are we rocking uh you're doing
stainless steel it is stainless steel
yeah
I
I don't know talk about the range is it
Viking uh the range is Wolf Wolf is I
know very nice someone else that's a
that's Italian right I know it's Italian
I think so yeah it's wolf then I'm
almost I mean I said it quickly yeah
yeah when you guys bought the place what
did you redo it you got it out and redo
it on the inside uh we did uh two-thirds
of it I'd say yeah okay it was uh um uh
some of it is we didn't do anything too
but a lot of it you know uh the kitchen
was on the second floor so we brought
that down okay that's now our master
bedroom and then we you know we did
various things and
um uh but some of it was we left it
because it's beautiful I mean sure
Brownstone I imagine yeah yeah 1800s
like 1900s and shoes off in the house
yes yes please yeah okay your guest as
well uh yeah yeah I mean no I wear shoes
it's just my guess all right
do a little Power Trip on them I like it
uh hmm
well you eat a hard-boiled egg in public
uh I don't particularly care for no I
probably wouldn't not because it's
people I'd be ashamed or anything but I
just don't care for our favorite things
okay uh anyone in your family own a PT
Cruiser
a specific question uh no okay what were
the cars like growing up what were the
family cars oh they were wonderful
window they'd have four wheels and
they'd go round and round you would uh
there was an internal combustion engine
look it up baby I swear to God
we had a we had a uh I don't remember
prior to
the we had eventually got a Dodge Dart
uh okay not bad with nothing on it and
then and we had that for a while
um
I think we just and then
and then uh I don't know we must add
something after that because that was
like real 70s AM radio with buttons you
know yeah yeah what are you whipping
around in now uh I have a uh 2012 uh
Toyota Highlander really that's what
you're floating around in all right I
like this hmm you do on the street
parking or you got a parking spot uh no
we got uh yeah no we don't have a
driveway no God no no that would be I
mean yeah and like dipmas park or
anything like that no okay yeah in the
garage Park in a garage that's pretty
good you take your shoes off on a plane
um I I would yep I have for sure and if
uh um I wouldn't if they if I thought
they were gonna smell bad or anything
sure definitely not do that
um but I will
you know quietly and to myself sure kick
the shoes off you don't make a scene of
it no not at all subtle I like it classy
gentlemen do you travel first class give
somebody if they're flying out for work
if somebody's uh paying for it yeah I do
uh but I will do what I will pay for is
the Comfort Plus or the the extra leg
room I definitely do that you're a Delta
man I presume by the Comfort Comfort
plus
um yeah well we go Atlanta a lot and uh
so I'm on Delta quite a bit and have you
been to the new LaGuardia yes holy [__]
it's awesome yeah it's nice it's way
different than it used to be it's so
great are you a lounge man you do the
lounges no but I would uh oh I'll tell
you where I do the lounge I'll tell you
exactly uh uh where I will pay for it
probably the only time I've done it but
I've done it several times is the Virgin
Atlantic Lounge in London probably
that's like the pub that's probably it
right it's it's
it's beyond like it's crazy and I will
we my wife and I you know I spent a lot
of time in London years really and uh
and did a lot of flying back and forth
and you know that's a that's a big
flight it's a it's a hump yeah and
we would go to the airport early
specifically knowing that we were gonna
go yeah and I respect that yeah we it's
it's pretty amazing but they're they're
really not worth it you know it depends
well do you get it through do you have a
do you uh Rewards member with Delta you
have a yes frequent flyer number yeah
I'm but I've never used it for the
lounge
um wait a minute that can't be true
um or if you have an American Express
they eat a lot too yes I I just switched
over actually not not too long ago but
uh there's um
I know I've been in the American when I
know that a flight's delayed uh and then
I add up I'm not that sounds like a
joking but I'm not I will add up how
much will the wine or beer cost cost
more bar versus getting the lounge thing
and I've so I've done that uh at least
five times where I've gone like that's
next level I mean if it's if you're
doing beer math at the airport
but if you get like a two-hour delay
sure then [__] it I'm going to the
lounge and I'll just drink that's gonna
be fifty dollars in beer absolutely he's
tight with the cash I respect it a
little bit yes what's your drink yeah
what's your drink of choice it totally
depends uh and it also depends on what
time I'm flying and all that but it will
it will either be like an IPA or a
Cabernet so if I'm going wine it's
Cabernet classy and if it's uh uh beer
it's like an IPA if you had a nice
dinner what's your cocktail of choice I
don't drink cocktails I drink cocktails
I don't not because I I just don't like
like them that much and I I will have
wine or beer depending what it is or
sake
um and then I'll drink tequila and I'll
drink it you know straight straight so
really yeah if I'm like kind of going
when it comes to the booze he's pretty
refined yeah give him that all right all
right but tequila I would fall into the
cocktail category he made it seem like
he only has beard wine you skip over the
mixer and go straight to the straight to
the swords I do I just don't like like
um like my sister's way she's a big food
she's an amazing chef and everything but
uh and she's like the mayor of Atlanta
everybody knows her and uh and we'll go
to these restaurants places and she's a
big cocktail person and you know she's
always insisting like oh my God this
this is amazing take a sip and I'll
that'll be yeah that's all right but it
just take it's like the palomers and the
groanings all that kind of stuff I'd
rather just have my beer and then later
have tequila are you a share the apps
kind of guy are you an individual
oh sure sure share everything yeah why
not all right
that's kind of a dick move sure some
people very specific about it that's
shitty uh-huh hmm I can't get a reader
he's a back and forth I feel a lot have
have you ever had poison ivy as an adult
uh no I mean as a teenager teenager yeah
okay you have baking soda in the fridge
at the house
um [__] I should I have before I don't
know but probably should okay I'm not
opposed to it who's doing the cooking
over there you do you do
um my wife's a really good cook uh but
I'm I make big large batches of soups
and stews okay and uh so I will make
you know I'll Triple A recipe for you
know whatever it is uh you know in fact
we were finishing up the mushroom barley
soup that's in the fridge
86 to split B and I'll I'll freeze half
of it and then uh
um but I do I that there's kind of
consistently something and I'll
experiment
um with with different things and uh
but my wife's a good cook with like the
the saute pans and the roasting kind of
stuff the key Foods things really
throwing me off no Whole Foods no
Traders no no oh yeah I go to Trader
Joe's but I don't make a special trip
like if I'm going to the grocery store
just to get Staples you're just gonna
hit I but I don't go uh like uh my
dentist is by the
um Trader Joe's on Atlantic and in uh
Cobble Hill and Forum Hill rather and uh
so I'll bring my backpack if I have to
go to the dentist and I'll go to Trader
Joe's and get stuff there they have you
know I love Trader Joe's but I don't
like go hmm I need onions and a chicken
and da da da I'll get on my bike and go
to Trader Joe's I'll [__] it'll go down
the foods will you do that though you'll
take the bike down to the grocery store
it like not really like the the one the
I used to
he's a man of the people I used to uh
you took the subway here too yeah yeah
man what I like it guys what I don't
know what class a person you're
expecting
um come in here and throw 20s at us
um call Us dirt bags yeah that's my
neighborhood it's my uh I mean there's
I'm by a food town and I'm by you know
various places but I'm also really uh
uh uh you know I look at the
um UPI number always uh you know I grew
up poor unit price index yeah so you're
so you're looking yeah like if you buy
uh sure it tells you price per unit yeah
exactly so you're you're looking you
know this you think you're like oh this
olive oil's nine dollars and this olive
oil is 25 but really when you look at
the size you're actually paying more for
the you know really yeah you just got to
look at the the you know the two numbers
on a yeah so look at the left look at
the left number and that'll tell you
whether you're getting not ripped off
but what you're paying for and uh oh I'm
I'm I'm uh
that's all stuff and it drives my wife
nuts because she had the opposite
experience you know um and
and uh
she stands up like you you've been
nominated
I got 84 episodes of the rest of the
development here just get the olive oil
let's go yeah yeah that's classy as [__]
yeah damn it's yeah
yeah any fast food
oh yeah what's your favorite
um
I mean uh not I don't really ever have
fast food in New York but when I'm out I
mean I yeah cookout man down down in
Georgia I well I'm a cookout man here no
I mean the the place cookout no I've
never even heard of it you've been the
cookout yeah never heard of it in
Georgia yeah they're in Georgia or North
Carolina what what is it burgers and
stuff burgers and stuff shakes a little
a little bit slower fast food never
heard of it wow and it's in Atlanta it's
in Atlanta yeah and there's a line 24 7.
there's a line of cars around the corner
where is it uh it's it's all over the
South I think they're like chain I think
I don't remember never even heard of it
or seen it uh okay I'll check it out but
I like I mean I'm I like in and out I
like uh
um Shake Shack I like uh okay
Chick-fil-A Chick-fil-A is great I mean
like Popeyes or like uh what else
um
there's a Popeyes in Brooklyn I don't
know exactly where it is but it's like
it looks like it's kind of Popeyes the
original one but it's this one's like
perfect where is it I can't remember
exactly where it is it's clean it's nice
came to him in a dream one time that I'm
not aware of that one
that one has escaped me uh you gotta
come to the fat guy meetings uh have you
ever ordered anything off QVC or as seen
on TV no no okay can you whistle with
your fingers
oh yeah I can do a sloppy you can yeah
okay but not the good I mean both but I
have to put some things
that's pretty and then it gets all wet
and I have to it takes me a little while
but yeah I've always been jealous of the
people who can don't use any fingers and
just like a loud oh there's a screamer
yeah
um do you have any answer to water sure
of course thank you
um
do you have any aunts or uncles that you
don't call or anyone in your family
don't you that you don't call by their
real name
like an Ann cookie or an uncle fingers I
guess that's a bad choice but you know I
have an ant fingers thank you so much uh
no I don't know let me think here uh
no no
do you like the following smells asphalt
gasoline horses magic marker
do you enjoy them no yes no no no okay
uh what was the last meal you've had
delivered
um
Thai food
yeah pretty classy and if when it comes
will you eat it out of the container
will you plate it on a plate from your
kitchen always it infuriates my wife I
will not only will I eat it out of the
container I'll eat it out of the
container standing over the sink really
yeah
this guy's Bonkers dude he's all over
the place yeah have you ever been kicked
out of a sporting event
yes I have really yeah I wrote about it
um I was
as as I
intimated earlier I'm a big baseball fan
and um uh been to
hundreds and hundreds of baseball games
uh in my life and when I started making
money uh I would we get tickets to uh
you know playoff games I was Braves fan
growing up and then a Red Sox fan and
then and simultaneously because they're
both different leagues and um uh
and I went I and I would always take a a
friend somebody I knew you know liked
baseball and my sister in fact my sister
and I were at the the game winning when
the Braves in 95 won the World Series
against Cleveland we were it was the
last game at that Park
um which I kind of grew up growing up in
and watched a lot of Braves games and uh
and we were at that I took her to that
uh game was thrilling and um uh so I was
at I want to say 90s
six I believe it was uh I can
like it was it was the Braves Yankees
and I was at uh
uh Turner Field
um and maybe it was right before 96
because they turned that into the
Olympics I can't remember but it was uh
Braves Yankees and uh
my friend I brought my friend Craig
Williams who's my high school buddy of
mine and we went we're watching the game
and
I uh
I can't remember what oh I remember so a
bunch of people left the Yankees were
winning people in our section and I'm
talking like you know
20 people left and
these two women uh in full Yankees uh
you know stuff came down and just like
anybody does you see empty things we're
gonna move up sure get better seats so
they came they sit down and uh
and then I and then uh the security came
to boot them out and I'm sitting I'm
like in the middle so I'm good there's
like a good 10 12 seats I'm like you
know uh and I've been drinking you know
uh and I'm like let them stay oh you
know whatever and then I start uh
peppering my all in good spirits not
like Angry yelling at them but like let
them stay this nope nobody's [__]
here and I start uh peppering that and
then uh somebody complained an old
southern guy who a little a den I'll
just skip ahead I saw him at another
game uh like two years later it was when
Atlanta whatever it was Atlanta was
playing St Louis I believe and take the
[__] out of them uh no he also I
recognize him like you're the guy had me
thrown out and he's like you know we
don't need we don't need that language
here and you know all that kind of stuff
and then he gets security and security
comes and I'm not even aware they're
there and literally behind me with the
two meaty hands I'm like let's go like
the cream kidding me are you [__] you
kidding me and uh and they kicked me out
damn they kicked me out of the World
Series for swearing Jesus and I wasn't
even swearing at anybody I was going hey
you [__] [__] piece of [__] you
know it was none of that I was like two
yeah and I'm like uh oh just let him
stay there's nobody [__] here come on
what who do you care it's the seventh
inning and they and I got kicked out of
the World Series that's crazy let me ask
you this if you were at a baseball game
and you were in the Outfield
and a home run came your way but I'm
literally in the outfield on the Press
Play in left field what happened oh my
God I gotta get my glove no no gloves oh
no no no and you're wearing a suit what
the [__] uh if you were out in the
stands in the Outfield a home run came
your way you got the Home Run do you
keep that ball or do you give it to a
little kid
uh who hit it uh
oh that's a that's not a great answer
yeah so you got to give it to the little
kid oh fine in your made-up hypothetical
yes not only do I give it to the child
but I take that child and adopt him will
you keep a judge's home run uh if you
would have caught that yeah yeah yes
I'll buy the kid like an uh you know a
bicycle or something
get him again get him an ice cream
season tickets
that's a tough spot I know you're a big
baseball fan uh hmm and so we were at
the World Series this year yeah oh wow
yeah that was all right boy I hated that
team got thrown out for the Phillies oh
yeah really yeah well over the Astros no
no I hate the Astros all right I respect
both teams I respect them but uh how'd
you hate the fills this year they're a
hatable team I don't think you really
yeah they're not that's all we have here
today folks
and the fans are kind of douchey too
you're talking about us right now yeah
and they don't dress well and I hear the
ones bald the other one's fatty [__]
that's just what I heard fans
the above the flight attendant when
you're on a flight
you hit the Bell I'm yeah I'm if I'm on
the window seat and uh I need something
yeah okay as opposed to what hey
throwing an Apple at them hey lady oh
God hey lady sorry could you tap the
person in front of you and have them tap
the person in front of them and have
them tap the person uh what are you
leaving for the uh for the hotel
cleaning service if you're there for one
night uh one night is five dollars
anything over that uh and I clean up
after myself yeah I was raised to clean
up and I clean up put the towels in a
pile yeah I I do everything I don't do
yes I don't there's a lot of whites I'm
I'm you know it's another weird thing
sure I'm the same way I'm the same yeah
I organize I get I don't want to make a
I don't want someone to walk in and be
like oh this guy's an animal yeah yeah
like it's the proper thing to do for
sure uh anyone in your family ever
interviewed on the local news
I don't and not for like winning an
award or anything yeah not for winning
an award
uh talking about a car accident okay
yeah okay I don't think so do you have
any quail eggs in your refrigerator
right now no any fireworks in your house
right now
uh yes really yeah
David Cross has fireworks yeah man all
right magazines in the bathroom
uh ammo yeah
you never know who's coming through the
window you've seen the porn movies
you've seen the Bourne movies
12 gauge next to the toilet
um what kind of air freshener you have
in the car right now in the Toyota
Highlander we do not have an air
freshener we're all dogging it okay are
you reading a book right now I am really
uh yes I'm reading the Robert Carrow
book the biography of uh um Robert Moses
which is a [__] it's a monster
it's 1200 Pages city planner Robert
Moses yeah that's pretty classy when you
go to bed at night is it do you have a
TV in the bedroom no no TV in the
bedroom absolutely do you read before
you go to bed
um I mean not as much as I should
sometimes I do but uh I I mean not that
often really but when so when you go to
bed you're going to bed yeah and how
many pillows do you use just two two
behind your head yep sleep on your side
or on your back side really fan on you
uh well we have a overhead fan if it's
hot yeah you have that going yeah if
it's yeah if it's required pretty classy
king size bed I assume
dude let me tell you something we I've
never been uh with my wife uh in a
king-sized bed until well probably in
some motels or whatever but we we got
one when we moved into this uh which
will be the last place I ever lived and
um that was the intent when we got it
and remodeled it and stuff and uh
uh
we got a king-sized bed and [__] what a
difference
it's a total and now when we sleep in a
queen-size bed it's like what do you
might as well over here that's crazy and
the king-size bed it's like you're in
two different zip codes it's awesome
it's only like it's only like a seven
inch or eight inch different but it's
like it's the world it's so crazy it's
so crazy uh all right we gotta wrap it
up here I got one more for you when was
the last time you drank Mountain Dew
oh I mean probably in my teens okay wait
do you do any soda not really no I used
to uh drink Coke non-stop I mean just
that's all he drank yeah uh and I I
I haven't had soda in a long long time
okay okay you said when he came in that
you were gonna be garbage but I'm seeing
all class you ever crash a golf cart
I've been thrown out of a baseball game
um for mild abusive language that's his
side of the story who knows what really
happened he's stolen a can of clams and
his mom was in on it all right would you
put it like that he sold greeting cards
door-to-door in a blizzard
you own any Birds no what was your first
concert
oh uh my first concert was the uh The
Kinks with John Mellencamp not John
Cougar Mellencamp yet okay John
Mellencamp opening up and
we is this pre-jack and Diane
uh must have been yeah okay and it was
um uh
it was the best little scam I would have
been 15. there we go see no no I mean
that anybody can do um so
he it was it was my friend who who
arranged this whole thing and uh and you
we were uh volunteered to be ushers and
you just have to bring I think it's uh
whatever I believe is like a white shirt
and a red vest or a black vest and dark
pants and
um and
and this is all like planned ahead of
time and my my friend must have heard it
from like his older cousin or something
like that and so we went down to the Fox
Theater in Atlanta down to Midtown and
and we we got there early and he had our
shirt and our vest and we listened to
the [__] 30 minute spiel about what
to do what not to do and here's a and I
remember the guy was like cartoonish uh
uptight guy with a mustache and southern
guy and uh
and then
literally minutes into the concert
ditched everything put on a t-shirt
which we brought with us and then we
were just in the crowd and that was it
and enjoyed the whole show he's trash I
respect the move but the Kennedys ain't
doing that
ladies and gentlemen oh my God Mr David
Cross that was like I appreciate it
coming in he got the spring tour coming
up anything else you want the folks out
there to know
uh no spring tour go I mean go to my
website officialdavidcross.com that'll
have all the cities and dates and there
will be more coming so you don't have to
write me going hey no good dance and you
know we'll get there we'll get playing
Kodiak this year got a problem with us
yeah ah buddy thank you so much that was
fantastic Kippy what do you got for him
guys we're all over the road uh our
third show at the Gramercy theater
there's still some tickets left so get
those tickets now we appreciate all the
support thank you we love you gang and
we'll see you next week peace